- On this episode, I talk
about Pinterest on Twitter,
a kosher Latin food truck
and Facebook running television ads?
In the UK?
(hip hop music)
(audience cheering)
You ask questions, and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
(hip hop music)
(chews noisily)
Hello everybody and welcome to episode 75
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
I am your host Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and I am eating.
This is the kind of crap I eat now
as I build up my muscle.
Episode 75 guys.
This is, you know, we are almost to 100
and the final episode.
Final episode 100 is going to be huge.
More details to come.
India, let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Matthew asks,
"You said Pinterest and Twitter
speak different languages.
"Is it wrong to have my Pinterest account
"tied to my Twitter account
so when I post to Pinterest
"It auto-posts to Twitter?"
- Yes, Matthew.
It is wrong, but it's not super wrong.
You know, automation has a part
where, you know, I continue to test
what's scalable, what's not.
The reason it's probably wrong is
you'd probably get a lot more value
and we all do it, I do it, I
continue to test the wrong way
to make sure about the right way.
For example yesterday I put, you know,
we have started putting out pictures
that are completely native
to Twitter in the forum.
Yesterday's photo of me and AJ, you know
high five surround yourself
with people with permission.
In the old days, excuse me.
In the old days
I would have put the
Instagram link in Twitter.
And it would have looked like
crap in that crazy screen
that is Twitter.
It would have had a link to Instagram.
You know, Twitter has made
Instagram not native upload.
And I would have drove
people to that photo.
But now with the original piece of content
that got a great engagement.
Over 100 retweets and favorites yesterday.
And I accomplished the storytelling
that I wanted on Twitter
instead of using Twitter as a distribution
to drive towards Pinterest
for the added efficiency
that created automation.
Automation's great
if you're just trying
to make things happen.
Meaning like if you're just
trying to get the task done.
But what about the result
that you're actually trying,
like why do you tweet?
You tweet to get your message out.
And thus, you need to make content native.
So I would say it's wrong.
Because if you take that same pin,
whatever you're trying
to achieve on Pinterest,
and you cropped, what's the crop area,
we don't, none of the
designers are here, right?
Dammit, you know.
If you cropped it
appropriately by default,
let me, they took my phone too.
If you cropped it
appropriately it'd do better.
So the answer is yeah, it's a mistake.
- Hey Gary, Mottel from Twitter
here and I wanted to ask you
I have a kosher Latin food
truck at South by Southwest.
How can I best promote it?
And how can I get you to
stop by for a free taste
of some of our great kosher Latin food?
See you in Austin.
- You know, the best way
you could promote it is
to get on the #AskGaryVee Show, check.
Can I stop by, yes, check.
It's double check, M!
- Gary, since the robots
seem to be taking over
in about five years,
where do you see the role of mankind
in an economy where physical productivity
isn't really even an issue any more?
- David, the robots are not
taking over in five years.
Not even close.
The robots may take over in 55 years.
And so since that's so far out,
I can't wrap my head around it.
But if the robots take over,
I've got to be really
dead honest with you.
I'm not worried about the productivity.
I'm scared crapless that
the robots took over.
- Hey Gary, it's DJ Vallauri
from Lodging Interactive.
My question for you is
what's your sales process
when you're working with a prospect?
How involved are you with your sales team
in pitching concepts,
ideas, strategies, tac--
- VJ,
I'm heavily involved
in getting the client.
New business pitches
I'm massively involved.
Our success rate is over
the top with me involved
compared to me not involved.
But once they come in, I'm
more on the hunting side.
On the farming side, I've a lot of SVPs
high level strategists
who learn the business
and then are pitching
on a day to day basis.
Don't forget we, we're
heavy retainer-based
and then we do incremental above.
And so the retainer base
kind of takes care of it,
and then the incrementals added value.
So there's a little less stress for me
to make sure that's checked off.
But the SVPs, the senior
people driving the business,
are the ones that really are involved
in the incremental sales
pitch day in and day out.
And I'm really involved in
up front locking it down.
And that is a scalable model.
Because if I do my thing,
and it locks it down
and creates that base,
and if I can create it
that it's profitable,
not that everything is up side after that,
then that's a good business model.
- [Voiceover] David asks,
"What are your thoughts
"on Facebook and their need
to start TV advertising?"
- David, great question,
and I'm really excited
about answering this.
You have to understand
that everything to me
is an arbitrage.
So for most businesses in the world
that don't have complete reach, right?
TV is not the best value,
hence your hashtag.
However, for a company
the size of Facebook
that has reached everybody at some level,
they've got two places
they can go left, right?
Which is, and notice it's in the UK.
They can go, they can go,
they're struggling a little with 13 to 15
but they're not going to be
able to market to them on TV.
I can get them into the pipeline
where Snapchat's winning.
And then they can go
actually much older, right?
If you look at the dynamics of, like,
and this is not much older.
But if you look at the
dynamics of 70 to 90,
there's still maybe some upside there.
And TV has some awareness.
I think it's overpriced, but when you have
a market cap of 225 billion,
that's a hell of a lot more interesting
to actually do some TV and
have some justification
over somebody who has a
market cap of 50 billion.
Or 50 million, or five
million, or 500,000.
Get it?
So to me, I can see some justification
around that tactic.
You know, it may cost
them a lot more for a user
but when when you're
left to so little users,
you've got to pay a lot more.
Whereas for all of us,
there's so many users left,
we have to pay as little
as possible to have an ROI.
Everything is, there is
no one size fits all.
There is no absolute statements.
And you've got to make
decisions for your exact moment,
Facebook television ads in 2005,
'06, '07, '08, '09, '10 eh.
2015 in the UK market?
More interesting.
Guys, thank you so much
for watching the show.
We need a lot more questions on Instagram.
I'm calling for it now.
If you care about this show at all,
if you want it to last past 100 at all,
this is your only chance.
Ask a question on Instagram,
here is the link to how to do it.
Do it now, it matters.
Question of the day:
where are your parents from?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)